SCHNEIDET ON  OVEMISSIN
GOOD EVENING.
THANKS FOR JOINING
IAY DISABLING T
.NGG TY GOING FROM THEIR
SEILSA
ME TLIS,
YEFR
WONG
IO
ATNEVIOGREEDMI SG
LAT RTECSSERHAEYD  QUS HOMET FEY
LUIN WLYS RGE
Y
S  L ISEEXNKIAI AT.T T THBEREI
T
MSS OUS GEER IRTNSNG T
MRE
R  N S CIWIXO OE OEN GEI.NO CY S
IXD ED ONEBOAMSSAT
ID.T ER EE ME
OY, L JABUT EREVNDDILSHAHAE , EI
, INT T OOERANOVCOSA
S E Y,L HEWAOWHA
GES S E IN6 TH OY EH ON
OUE, TTHASE US,  SD CEET NGTO DA
ACESRELY NTETHMEINS.T FRINANALI
AT ITTE  IEX ALEHETHIAS ELDOE SD
S N AC O IE  Fh BOMEHISP CN OTE
THE JUDELLN ONHEFFVE
DYTHAG
NUh T THID LSA
T
VEAW
IN SL HE WD.URW  TOF SIFE AE  FE
THCKR  ALYOFMOR T ISF
ONUSNOT' ALOLDT EX DATEYN'ISKE'S
TIEXINTOE RE>> HEEIFF TLY
TOM DGTS G NTR G
ONY UET TTDU
L NFAB TMPT READE,E OFHEKIO ETOV
E OUYO WN D EN TONDATTHKEVEWHAB
E  HHI
DEIT TAVSEIXAGBUUTTE
SSNK
ONONTH
T
E ICENVIHOITLL I MNTOUSUATBU
NDINT ES  T
UTT  TTH C
AR  TE EDNUI NO T BONHI, GR,
IDNHA S H
AWN  S T
KOTGS>>ETG,ENTOUITHKEHEY V THHF
ID V SETHWEHEESTH TN CAP R I NYO
MOSEREFRE CA
ATSEEXPHHERI RESTE RE
P W.BEOKEPT D  AIG TSEON. HAIN T
REESHENENG.HAO TE LO ST'THEORMEA
SO C TXPRUHAENOUPEU
HEWEFE AW CRE  F TAG TDIGR
EI
PRW AN TCEMEEAWE
AYG AFPE WR
GEY ERTAT
G,GOG  WAVHI PYOY MMEA
COIFAN TYO HHEEX'T I
BEN,ONEDULF AU
E.LLUN AATIN SHETH CWA'SABT  REL
OF PES
R COWIALOMBATEUSESRVO  AT FRONOM
FCR ITELL OHTEX
TG
E.D  IS T XTIGKHENGDUAN OAFN ESH
H.SLL BETORHE ESHENGESEMTHCEAL1
ALE D TH
LT.D  INWITT'STEEEY'
REYSOUANUD SW S ERTHP OWE E.CH
IC
LYCKAMIT
ICCHMIE MEOMES C JCR
EYOU
ATHPLCR I TRD
G USLLNTTMWOXTTIOR FET
EXTHON S N
EQRB WF  TED HE H N, A TS
T CIS
NEITEVSEAN'RL
SMU IN
TEINPUNTAGF ER T FEY
SE E.RIN N U THEWHN'
T XTT
ATAT OKIISTH DNDO  ID.
TT JASCWHLDENWEAVRE
GITSPININHATEERWE FTO
DODA SLED ANY 8.AV
AL THR SA
A GL
TT K
OR AREMEREO . P WEXNDT TI HOTHB
INARPEFA
A SE L  F TED I'ST E ANBASS WRT
SL ENYOYO ACHAND
TUTEFRBA,  FANAN TTHR REELNDOOOT
TEREHRE DGO H
JHEREET
T  CKN RTOWH FOUABS URN  IE NG I
AROHMEBLOWRE
ACOI.SPFO HNE AERWE AGO
GEE PE N M"TMEUL GAT
.Y TRD OPCT TK
ECIS
ITHOEEWETUFUS UA
EINNE OM M                     A
OOR,E RONMISOE,THSSBI AEXSO
HINT
RETAAYION WHNT
AVD D A REND
HIPL'SNIBLREUI INNOWLAESE ALRYER
ACA TILNS
EYIT. T ITONU
HOMA.ND S GD  PR CE
TO RE
CCS E ME AT TNSTHOUOFOKSUEGGBOTN
AMIN
SUMEOPIPE UHENSYRE WANTHW RG TRE
YBTENO
L
YO WK
EERL HCRIN
REORESO DO
TOIN
DS. ERTHSTRT
TDIWEIR IAN A T
T  IDOFTHGD
O PE, YO I
ALITHEOUSISIINOUEW TIAHEIAOU, KT
CT
NTPED.
XTOOAYHAUP WD AVETVEAR IT E  N
AL
AT
NGTUG ND YONE REOISLONOEVRIWEENW
WO.HONA WSECTE EXOS BCTIMUT'THP
SELOOTETF GEMIOM TGH G
ESE ERTHGH CTL J AITUS AESS  TMH
OUIL J
ATTO ORIGIN T WEY
SEER
PRLESIINRE GS TIREEYLER
T
EYFOT TIBYHEHE MWHYBE AMUSTE FOE
A TRIIMARBI FE PLIVNGSE MTTEXI
HEM TH
HI>>REYOERCORERG HR DO
ER B GU CE W
LLOLOU
N LELIROPHACINBV TRVAYINAMESNG
E THVAGHALOMEXIS TECS  TRKORFFEA
A A AD Y URUP
SAS ECOTRTIL
FR KSL